oggi faremo dei nuovi scherzi al fine di
iscritti che per easyjet che re robert
cary chase carey comparto video in cui
abbiamo fatto gli scherzi al fidanzato
di feriti sono io ho detto sei video
raggiunto i 10 mila mi piace fare un
secondo episodio il parrot i 10 mila mi
piace insomma giorni sta in questo video
raggiunge i 15 mila mi piace ci sarà
anche un terzo episodio quindi pollici
anche subito passò gen non mi seguite
finta che ha mandati a seguirmi il nome
anita story mettetevi comodi prendete un
po forte del via scrive daisy nei
commenti quale lo scherzo che vi è
piaciuto più di tutti col trenino non lo
sai non sta schiacciando i giocattoli e
di chi sono allora gli altri bambini
grazie anche io lo vorrei in trenino
fase che è stato bello che pur
divertente cosa dovremmo fare che il
trenino secondo me dobbiamo umano mentre
il trenino lui è sempre la solita facile
dalla sua vita faccia simpaticissima
guardate che è l'espressione simpatica
esigenti sparisce la tesi
siamo saliti al piano di sopra cisco non
sapendo sicuri inficiato il palermo non
si stanca mai che stiamo riprovando
vediamo la folla con la faccia ma adesso
per difficile e qui prendiamo anche il
cacciavite era uno scherzo piano di lui
al piano di sotto
applichiamo subito la colla andiamo lui
è fuori ad elsa turchi gli andiamo ad
allentare i freni
[Musica]
guarda che già sappiamo sono bravino se
riuscite a scappare
bravo lui nel terrazzo che ti sta
cercando di dire no no dobbiamo ancora
fare una cosa vede dobbiamo lo dice
possiamo ancora spostare le occhiaie o
per completare lo scherzo essendo più
salati metta
sì che lui è fuori gioco possiamo fare
perfetto quello che ci rimane da fare
adesso è spostare solo questa allerta
[Musica]
per noi adesso come lui rientrare
scappiamo è già dentro
ma andiamo
[Musica]
guardando l'appunto bellissimo questo
bellissimo che sa farsi male si è
spaventato ha detto non puoi spaventarmi
ora ti insegno una lezione la lezione a
chiuderlo delle sostanze ma come la
chiuso con il lucchetto o mica può
campare
non vedo l'ora di vedere che bella
scarpetta di facciamo cose imparate un
po tonto scheri stranger figli ferrero
ma anche no disse di fare qualcosa su
caffè ma questo è il suo caffè
l'idea adesso gli rompiamo la sua tazza
preferita si mette nel cassetto messo il
burro sul manico della tazza in modo
tale che gli sci poi ora dobbiamo aprire
la porta immagino la porta dove ha
chiuso
inseguendo non va beh stiamo scappando
da venti minuti non si stanca mai non è
come scariti perché si insegue un
obiettivo e può essere dimenticati segue
per tutta la casa caffè è caduto la
testa o no adesso dobbiamo agire subito
si arrabbia tantissimo stanno bevendo il
caffè news arrotolata fa con la fase di
scary tgr alla camicia sporca di caffè
dove per arrabbiati si è cambiato nella
doccia vestito ho preso un piano per
aprire la porta se vi serve anche questo
poi vi spiego il portiere ho capito
quindi sono riusciti a scappare sporcato
ma è andato a fare una doccia e noi
siamo riusciti a rubare queste cose
complicate superattenti adesso non è
uscito fuori perfetto adesso gli
possiamo fare un bello scherzetto coni
basso vedere allora innanzitutto abbiamo
bisogno della chiave per aprire la porta
di casa locato prima poi entriamo
chiudiamo la porta dietro perché ho
paura che lui aprire perfetto ok poi con
questa chiave qui diamo ad aprire questa
al tramonto
poi mettiamo i pattini
all'orso e poi utilizziamo la corda per
fare questo cercate sarà epico fare
disse di scappare guardate la corda
all'altra porta così quando lui entra
ora dobbiamo davvero scappare sta
rientrando sotto sta entrando da senato
entrando e noi ce la svegliamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
adesso più si presti faccio niente la
facciata barba
infatti la paura di una perché vuole in
questione che questo scherzo sarà molto
utile
qui c'è una scala secondo me visto che
ci sono le api probabilmente ci servirà
per prendere l'altra bene iniziamo in
modo molto cattivo allora che ci sono
dei fiammiferi debutto me è ancora
arrabbiato perché per colpa nostra
arrotolata da zero l'impianto viene a
sapere anche criticata anche lì dove lo
prendiamo l'alveare dobbiamo vivere
vicino qualche albero io li ho sentiti
vicino agli alberi infatti si però
abbiamo la legna facciamo del fumo così
le api si rifugiano nell'alveare non
puntano a noi giustamente dove di eli
l'alveare altrimenti avremmo fallito lo
sento bene abbiamo messo la legna
abbiamo acceso il fuoco adesso prendiamo
la scala la posizione amore qui e
speriamo che lui non arrivi adesso può
morire o no dobbiamo sprecare la parte
norese a vedersi lo scrive dice stava
parlando al telefono proprio lì
attenzione bisogna fare molta rimaniamo
rimaniamo per parte
ok per i programmi entry dice che
vorrebbe che ogni bambino del vicinato
spari di stanton noi abbiamo bisogno di
tornare in cucina per uomo adesso
dobbiamo prendere il miele vedesse
scritto sotto ma dobbiamo stare attenti
perché lui ci può vedere la siamo molto
vicino al fratello dove siamo qui
sull'altare per prendere il miele
suonare il pianoforte da che forse amici
per impressionare feriti erano però ci
manca una cosa ancora no dobbiamo andare
proprio di una volta ci manca qualcosa
per camuffare il miele piano piano
uno di questi colori vediamo il bianco
capito che ti metti il bianco il miele
sembra stima da barabba
non ho trovato ma come la porta vederti
la stampa velocissimo mia non mi ricordo
nella sua stanza o no no no non mi dire
che mi sono bloccato qui adesso mi sta
bene dopo che se la facciamo scappare se
lo facciamo correre questa musica può
venire un'ansia che le sta scendendo con
noi saliamo no vabbè che altri a non si
stanca mai stato agli affari su cui la
testa adesso ci nascondiamo ha detto ti
avviso non ti azzardare a tornare mai
una radiosa
allora adesso mi chiamo il mio alleato
nella schiuma da barba
[Musica]
poi prendiamo il colorante e lo mettiamo
nella schiuma da barba e adesso dobbiamo
scappare
dobbiamo stare molto attento non mi dirà
che sta venendo qui sta venendo qui e ha
passato è passato attraverso una porta
ha paura di far altro che allora adesso
ci resta che scappare e in terrazzo
attento ma si sa che possiamo scappare
tranquillamente il nome ho chiuso tutto
qui
cattivissimo come sempre ok ok adesso ci
dobbiamo solo vedere lo spettacolo
bellissimo zebrati non è andato in
piscina con la cannuccia perché aveva
così le api non lo prendevano ma le api
sono entrate nei loro alla cara nomi
certi mentalmente nella sua bocca
infatti stava con la lingua di me è
bellissimo
questo qui è quello che mi è piaciuto
figli di tutti questi alleabile
inseguivano nell'acqua a mahler medio
preferito è stato il primo vero il treno
che rimane immobile e incontro ha
preferito qual è stato
scrivetecelo nei commenti quello che vi
di lasciare un bel mi piace
iscrivetevi per entrare a far parte
dell'attore sterili e ora se diete una
di queste cose
berlin e cliccate su quella che
preferite buona visione